El neoliberalismo ha perseguido
y ha construido
1 sociedad donde el individuo está solo y desprotegido
ante el mercado
en manos del mercado
esclavo de lógicas consumistas,
1 sociedad fragmentada
y frágil, donde la gente está más conectada que nunca
a través de las redes sociales,
internet y perconectada digitalmente,
pero más
desconectada que nunca en términos humanos y sociales.
Se ha construido 1 subjetividad del individuo
pivotado sobre valores como la autonomía personal,
el espíritu emprendedor,
la seguridad en 1 o en 1 misma.
En definitiva,
en búscate la vida,
porque este no es 1 fenómeno meteorológico.
Y la solución no es echarle la bronca a la gente,
no es desconfiar de la gente,
y no es en ningún caso
pensar que la gente no es capaz de entender
lo que cuestan las cosas,
porque es que además hay cosas
que no se entienden
y además hay cosas
que no deben aceptarse.
Cuando investigadores posdoctorales
perciben 1 salario de €800 al mes,
tienen derecho a manifestarse
y es imprescindible que lo hagan
porque no estamos cuidando nuestro talento
si pagamos €800
a los investigadores y a las investigadoras
posdoctorales.
Cuando los jóvenes
acceden al mercado
laboral en condiciones de precariedad,
tienen derecho a alzar la voz
cuando se percibe 1 degradación
en el servicio de salud en osakideza,
que es tan evidente en el caso de la atención primaria,
los y las ciudadanos
tienen derecho a quejarse
cuando los precios de la vivienda
están fuera del alcance
de la Mayoría de los y las jóvenes
tienen derecho y tienen el deber de
expresarse. Ante esa situación,
la solución pasa por hacer 1 análisis certero
de las raíces del problema
y ponerles nombre
y plantear 1 política capaz de hacer frente
a este momento.
La identidad comunitaria,
el sentido de pertenencia a 1 comunidad
solidaria y abierta
es el ingrediente base
para fortalecer la cohesión social.
En nuestro caso,
esa causa es el proyecto Nacional Vasco,
la construcción
de 1 horizonte colectivo para nuestro Pueblo